in normal times we just be entering the
peak season for buying home and then the
pandemic hit according to the National
Association of Realtors home sales could
decline by 30 to 40 percent in the
months ahead for people who are house
hunting social distancing means some
brand new ways to get to know a property
Barry Peterson has more now I'll take
you into the kitchen this is one of my
favorite rooms in the house it's large
and bright we open up that fridge and
just so they see absolutely they are
well stocked for kovat denver real
estate agents mark and Lisa Kramer
co-owners of camber Realty are
demonstrating a whole new way of showing
properties with in person visits by
potential buyers no longer allowed in
Denver and many other states it's all
about going virtual and here we're
walking into an office this actually has
a former master bedroom before the
addition was put on in 2002 really one
of the coolest rooms in this house it's
it's large and it looks out onto the
parkway through this window here I have
used them for my personal real estate
transactions and they are using my house
as an example of how a tour will work
who's really gonna buy a house when all
they can see is a cell phone video of
the house a really motivated buyer
someone that's had a change in
circumstances a change in employment and
change in their family situation and
they need to move despite the situation
we're in right now since both Kramer's
work in real estate a slowdown cuts
right to the family's bottom line have
you cut back are you doing that yeah
absolutely we put away for a rainy day
and as I said to mark the other day it's
raining so John give me a reality check
April of 2020 versus April of 2019
what's the difference in your workload
100% Ted you're gonna love living here
John Nelson and his partner camo of
Nelson mote properties specialize in
multi
million-dollar homes in Palm Springs and
Southern California
you know the perception that most of us
have is that people who are buying
houses for two three five eight million
dollars are wealthy and that you know
what happens in the world doesn't really
bother them because they have a lot of
money in every level of the market if a
buyer senses that he has another
bargaining tool he's going to use it to
get a price reduction they just want to
work that work any way that they can so
sellers who can avoid the bottom fishing
buyers are and I spoke to a couple
agents at the high-end country clubs in
Palm Desert Indian Wells yesterday there
are sellers are pulling things off the
market they said you know if people are
out now our sense is that they're gonna
be bargain hunters let's just take it
off and go back on it go back on the
market next year it seems eerily
familiar to the market crash of 2008
except it isn't says Lauren's young
chief economist with the National
Association of Realtors we had a funny
subprime mortgages people were
stretching their budget and our soul
home builders going wild building homes
way too many in relation to the
population growth and when it crashed it
was very painful this time around
there's actually a shortage of
properties and that may help stabilize
the market and we anticipate will go
down significantly and then he will rise
back significantly but one thing that
will remain very stable is home prices
and this may actually be a good time to
buy because interest rate cuts mean more
people can qualify for a mortgage
Anita Padilla Fitzgerald is CEO of
Denver's megastar financially when I'm
independent mortgage banker would you
still make a loan today a regular
mortgage we're making lots of mortgages
today why considering all the
uncertainty and what we're all living
through well we want to help people buy
homes and take advantage of the low
interest rates
that's right over there with the
different shaped balconies knowing there
are potential buyers out there
frustrates diana crew who wants to
renovate and sell her late mother's
condo but people in the high-rise
consider non owners coming into the
building not appropriate in the safe
distancing times you have to be cautious
of the residents and they actually made
it very clear to us how uncomfortable
they were and we did get it but on the
other hand were stuck we don't know when
we can finish it so her agent Lee Vance
car will do what she's done before take
to the skies using a drone operator
location location location like all of
us Mark Kramer wonders what no one yet
knows what's ahead when in your mind
what's a short-time what's a long time
what's your expectation or hope our hope
is that we get through this by July if
we go well beyond that if we're looking
at you know next spring and we're still
in this situation it's gonna be a
difficult situation for the entire
country for the entire world for that
matter for CBS this morning Saturday
Barry Petersen Denver oh we bought and
sold a house and I've rented and
honestly I'm like I can't imagine doing
it virtually but so glad this technology
exists well as she mentioned if yeah if
you're if you're a motivated buyer it
happens it also be interesting to see
whether this whole thing changes where
people actually want to live city versus
suburbs